the x-men are facing their biggest
adversary yet and x-men apocalypse you
may be familiar with him from the 90s
animated series are we more or his
numerous appearance in past video games
with a convoluted past let's get into
who apocalypse really is based on the
comic ever since the world found out
about mutants in 73 there have been
cults who see them as some kind of
second coming or sign of God they call
themselves a sheer n7 yer named after an
ancient being they believed to be the
world's first apocalypse is said to be
the first mutant in the Marvel Universe
because he was born thousands of years
ago in Egypt with gray skin and blue
lips he was shunned and rescued by a
group called the sand Stormers given the
name n sabah nur he was brought up
following the philosophy of survival of
the fittest the Pharaoh Rama tut knew of
n sabah nur is destiny because he was
secretly a time traveler himself and
wanted his power for himself in sabah
newer find some advanced alien
technology moments before an attack and
his powers first manifested when posing
as a slave to infiltrate Rama Tut's
Empire having lived for centuries he
eventually has a couple run-ins with the
original x-men he makes it clear he's
been observing them and knows all about
their goal for peace apocalypse doesn't
really seem to benefit a peace between
humans and mutants since it won't push
mutants to grow and evolve this goes
back to his philosophy about survival of
the fittest as the x-men try to contain
him he fills them in on his story
apocalypse has often been seen as a god
he was believed to be set the god of
death in Egypt and also worshiped and
feared in Persia India and by the Aztecs
he offered recruits mutants to serve as
his four horsemen one mutant he
augmented and twisted was angel after
his wings had been severely damaged a
long-running goal of Apocalypse over the
years was gathering 212 most powerful
mutants so he could use her powers to
turn himself into a god like being it
didn't quite work out as he planned what
exactly can apocalypse do with his
exposure to the alien technology his
powers were augmented he has complete
control over the molecules in his body
and can alter his form during battles
and can also change his size he has some
degree of telekinesis telepathy
super-strength and a healing factor
along with his mutant abilities
apocalypse uses regeneration chambers
and can change or inhabit other host
bodies which essentially makes him
immortal in Xmen apocalypse and sabah
nour decides a world must be destroyed
and remade in his image the x-men will
have to band together once again to take
on apocalypse and his four horsemen for
more on apocalypses crazy history
including conflicts with cable mr.
sinister and Bishop go to Comic Vine
calm and be sure to read more comic
books
you